what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
explaining every battle style used by
the demon Slayers in komatsuna Yaiba
including ton zeroes breath of water
zenit ooze breath of thunder the
mysterious dance of the fire-god and
many more while watching demon slayers
these epic swordsmanship techniques
caught my attention right away so that
is why I decided to make this video I
hope that I can gain a better
understanding of all the different
fighting styles myself and I hope that I
can help clear things up for you guys as
well in case there is anything that you
are wondering about or in case you just
find it useful to have all the styles
listed and explained right here in one
place and on top of that me making this
video might have something to do with
how many people have been endlessly
asking me to start making Demon Slayer
videos both on social media and in the
comments to my other videos seriously
though guys I really appreciate all of
you who asked me to make demon slayer
content and since I'm loving this series
right now
it is my pleasure to honor your requests
if you'd like to see more demon slayer
content in the future please leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell there
will be some manga spoilers in this
video about the breath styles themselves
and their users but not about the plot
or what happens to the characters in the
story with that said if you don't want
any spoilers at all you have been warned
please proceed with caution let's start
things off by briefly explaining what a
breath style is the different breath
styles or battle styles are basically
different styles of swordsmanship that
are used by the demon slaying core each
style is used with an engine and blade
weapon usually a sword and the
Nietzschean blades are unique because of
their ability to kill demons if demons
are cut down with other types of weapons
they simply don't die each breath style
focuses around specific breathing
patterns which enable the users to
strengthen their bodies by increasing
their lung capacity and the flow of
oxygen in their blood this allows the
user to perform incredible feats
including supernatural movements and
techniques making it possible for the
demon slayers to take on the demons who
are of course much stronger the
normal humans I'm not sure if I've ever
actually talked about this here on the
channel but I hold a black belt in a I
dough which is the martial art of
Japanese swordsmanship in real life
martial arts like AI dough breathing
techniques plan absolutely fundamental
role and in fact the more you advance in
rank the more important breathing
techniques become it is only well after
reaching the black belt stage that
breathing techniques and spirit become
essential and once you become a really
high ranked martial artist like black
belt fourth Don or fifth Don you really
must concentrate on mastering your
breathing and your spirit but beyond
just martial arts there is scientific
evidence that breathing techniques such
as the ones used for meditation can have
a profound physical impact on our bodies
so this emphasis in Demon Slayer on
breath styles does make a lot of sense
even though mastering a specific
breathing technique in the real world
will not allow us to use supernatural
powers I still find it fascinating how
these various breath techniques form the
crux of demon slayers epic battle system
before we get into the Styles please
comment down below which style is your
favorite and why I am curious to see
which battle style is the fan favorite
now let's look at all the specific
breath styles in order of their
appearance in the series starting things
off with the breath of water the primary
instructor for this style is Sakon G or
Adachi and he was the one who taught
this style to both Tangier o and G you
tomioka Ciccone she also taught the
style to his former apprentices sabi toe
and mekomo who are currently deceased
but whose spirits helped to train
Tangier o breath of water has ten
initial forms and an additional eleventh
form that was created by gil Tomioka in
japanese these forms are called kata and
from my knowledge of martial arts the
correct English translation for kata is
form so that is what I'm gonna be
calling them the first form is water
surface slice which is basically a
single concentrated slash the second
form is water wheel which as the name
suggests involves the user jumping in
the air and spinning in midair in a
circular path in order to create an
attack that resembles a water wheel the
third form is dance of the rapid current
which involves the user swinging their
sword while mimicking the movements of
flowing water the
fourth form is striking tide which
involves using multiple consecutive
slashes while twisting the users body in
a way which resembles the power of a
water tide the fifth form is the
merciful rain of a dry day which allows
the user to kill the target in a
merciful way so that the enemy will not
suffer this is used on enemies who are
already defeated and helpless or enemies
who have willfully surrendered the sixth
form is twisting whirlpool which
involves the user sharply twisting their
upper and lower body and creating a
whirlpool that will cut through anything
in its path
the seventh form is piercing raindrop
the fastest technique of the breath of
water style it amounts to a single but
very quick and accurate stab the eighth
form is waterfall jar a vertical cut the
ninth form is water splash which allows
the user to adapt to shaky footing by
minimizing his landing time and the size
of the surface needed to land safely the
10th form is the dragon of change a
continuous slashing attack that becomes
more powerful with each new rotation
finally the eleventh form created by GU
is called Lalla as the name suggests the
user completely lulls their own body
into a motionless state and this allows
the user to engage a technique that
disables and nullifies incoming attacks
however this form is not without
limitation and too many fast attacks
will break through it next up we have
the breath of thunder style used by best
boy Sena to a Kazuma and it was taught
to him by the adorable old man
jiguro Kawashima the breath of thunder
style has seven known forms so far in
the story although at first
Zenit su is capable of using only the
first form this first form is
thunderclap and flash which allows the
user to move and slash the opponent with
incredible thunderous speed because this
is the only form that Zenit was capable
of using at first he does his best to
master it and maximize its effectiveness
as a result does any - learns how to
perform this technique six and even
eight times in rapid succession and xeni
- is also able to augment the speed of
this form as he strives to bring out its
full potential
the second form of breath of thunder is
lightning ball five separate lightning
attacks performed in a single moment
the third form is buzzing mosquito
Thunder a spinning wave of lightning
that explodes in all directions
the fourth form is distant thunder which
allows the user to create a thunder
strike from a distance the fifth form is
heat lightning a slashing attack infused
with lightning that burns the flesh and
the sixth form is electric lightning
shower which is a series of thunder
strikes capable of cracking the enemies
body the seven form is called flaming
Thunder God and this form is actually
developed by Zen Itza later on in the
story it allows the user to create a
dragon-like creature that emits fire and
thunder and it can be combined with the
god speed technique for maximum speed
then we have the breath of B style used
by other best boy inosuke hashiba
this style is believed to be descended
from the breath of the wind style and it
has the ability to enhance its users
sense of touch there is no known
instructor for the breath of the beast
style and it is assumed that inosuke
learned this while living alone in the
mountains presumably on his own because
he is such a savage mad lad there are 11
known Fang forms that this tile can use
including first bank pierce and extract
which allows the user to stab a targets
neck simultaneously with both of his
blades then we have second Fang rip and
tear which allows the user to slash a
target with both blades in an ex
formation
third Fang rip and devour which is
essentially two simultaneous slashes and
an enemy's throat fourth Fang mince 2
bits which is a flurry of diagonal
slices fifth Fang mad cleave which is a
slicing attack that lashes out in all
directions around the user sixth Fang
jagged na a decapitation technique
involving both swords seventh Fang
spatial awareness which gives the user
the ability to send subtle changes in
the air across a wide area and this
allows the user to identify the location
of all potential enemies within that
area we also have eighth Fang pig
assault which is basically in also get
just rushing his enemies and swinging
both swords with the intention of
decapitating them
we have ninth Fang godly undulation
slice which allows the user to dislocate
the joints on their arms in order to
extend the reach of his attack
tenth fangs circular fangs which is a
spinning attack that cuts everything in
sight and finally we have improvised
Fang throwing slices which is basically
a nose okay shocking his swords at an
enemy now let's talk about the dance of
the fire-god style which is a style that
raised a lot of interest when it was
introduced in the first season of the
anime this is a breath style known and
taught only by the Commodore family and
it is passed down from father to son
within the Commodore family the breath
of flames user Shinjiro Ren Goku
suggests that the dance of the fire-god
style is actually the original breath
the godly breath that was the first ever
created and the one from which every
other breath is derived and that is the
legendary breath of the son Shin judo
Arango KU considers all the other styles
to be inferior copies of the breath of
the son with that said we don't yet know
for sure that the dance of the fire-god
and the breath of the son are one in the
same but there are clues that panchito's
family has some form of direct
connection to the original breath of the
son user including the mark on tangelos
face and the hanafuda earrings which
bear the Sun symbol so it is possible
that the breath of the son style was
secretly passed down through town zeros
family in the form of the dance of the
fire-god the dance of the fire-god style
has so far been used by Tangier oh and
by his father tandro
who used the dance of the fire-god style
for a ritual ceremony once a year this
style has 10 forms including waltz which
is a single high-powered / Blue Heaven a
circular spinning slash similar to
waterwheel flame waltz an attack
composed of a vertical slash followed by
a horizontal slash waltz flash which is
a combination of flame waltz and send it
to thunderclap flash solar halo dragon
dance which is a combo attack that
involves combining mizzu COEs blood
burst with Don Geno's swordsmanship
tonzura sword turns red is engulfed in
flames and a flaming dragon emerges from
the blade we also have scorching crimson
mirror which is a move that uses two
horizontal slashes to defend town zero
from an incoming attack / heli and
rainbow a defensive technique that
allows the user to dodge quickly using
rapid twists and rotations
technique will leave after images and
confuse opponents we then have fire
chariot an attack that can be used right
after par Halley and rainbow in order to
attack the enemy while they are
distracted by the after images we also
have shining Sun stab which is an attack
made up of a single sharp thrust and
finally we have burning Sun a circular
spinning slash designed to defend from
frontal attacks next we have the breath
of the insect created by Shinobu corto
this style is a derivative of the breath
of flower and so by extension of the
breath of water despite the fact that
she lacks brute physical strength
Shinobu is able to use the breath of
insect style to make up for that by
combining stabs thrusts shallow cuts and
slashes with poison the shallow cuts and
slashes are used to inject wisteria
based poisons into the target and this
is what eventually takes the enemy down
rather than taking them out by
overpowering physical attacks such as
instant decapitation this style has four
known forms including dance of the
butterflies frolic which is basically a
jumping attack that slashes the opponent
several times in order to inject the
opponent with poison the ants of the bee
sting near fluttering a rapid dash at
the opponent with amazing speed followed
by a single thrusting attack that also
injects poison dance of the dragonfly
compound a hexagon a combo attack that
strikes the target six times in six
different areas injecting poison in each
area in order to increase the chances of
the enemy being overwhelmed by the
poison and finally the dance of the
centipede hundred legged zigzag which
involves the user running at full speed
in a zigzag pattern confusing the
opponent and creating an opening for a
powerful poisonous thrust now let's talk
about the breadth of flames a breath
style used by Shintaro and Kyoto
Ren Goku this tile has at least nine
forms but not all of them have been
revealed at this point in time the ones
that we do know include first form sea
of fire an attack that involves the user
charging their opponent and swinging
their blade with the intent of
decapitating the enemy second form
ascending blazing sky which is an upward
slash attack fourth form wave of blazing
flames which involves the user's
spinning their sword rapidly in order to
defend from enemy attack
fifth form flame tiger which involves
multiple sword slashes that form the
shape of a tiger and finally esoterica
ninth form purgatory a fiery slash from
a distance that has the power to
obliterate everything in sight including
the terrain itself the other forms of
the breath of flames are currently
unknown next up is the breath of sound
this tile is used solely by the sound
pillar tank and kazooie and this tile is
actually derived from breath of thunder
similar to echolocation yuzu is capable
of deconstructing an opponent's
movements into bass sounds analyzing the
sounds and identifying openings and
weaknesses based on those sounds which
he then exploits this tile has three
known forms including first form thunder
which involves the user raising his
swords above his head and slamming them
into the ground thereby creating
explosions that sound like thunder
fourth form death Nell's oh Avicii
rest in peace of Ichi an attack that is
both offensive and defensive in nature
it involves the user spinning his swords
while simultaneously releasing bombs at
his targets and fifth form harmony of
shrill strings which involves the user
spinning his swords on a chain while
releasing bombs at the same time then we
have the breath of love style used by
love pillar meet suti Connor og derived
from the breath of flame style this tile
can only be used by Mitsui because of
her unique physical Constitution meaning
that her moves cannot be duplicated by
anyone else known forms include first
form shiver of first love on a tag that
involves a rapid - followed by multiple
slashes
second form anguish inducing love a
thrashing slash attack third form lovely
kitty shower a rapid succession of
ranged attacks fifth form wavering
attachment a backward somersault through
the air that creates a long string of
whipping attacks which eventually result
in her sword coiling around the targets
neck and sixth form Kitty pallav breeze
which involves the user twirling upside
down and creating helix shaped slashes
that can deflect enemy attacks now let's
talk about the breadth of flower style
this tile is originally derived from
breath of water and it is used by Conoco
cho and canal duty known forms include
second form plum spirit a series of
rotating sword slashes used a fan
to lead to deflect attacks forth forms
safflower robe a single slash of the
sword that also twists and curves 5th
form peony of futility a compa move that
features nine flowing consecutive
attacks in the final known form is
Scarlet Spider Lily is a technique that
raises the users kinetic vision to its
maximum power while this can be
extremely useful in battle it is also a
dangerous technique because it puts a
lot of strain on the user's eyes and it
can lead to partial or complete
blindness next up is the breath of wind
style it is used by wind pillar sanam e
shinozuka wa its forms include first
form dust whirlwind cutter a cyclone of
sword slashes second form claw purifying
wind a slash that creates four blades of
wind in the shape of a claw that cut
into the enemy third form clean storm
wind tree for which the user creates a
whirlwind around themselves by slashing
the sword all around their body fourth
form rising dust storm a downward swing
of the sword from multiple directions
fifth form winter Gale a multi-pronged
strike from above and sixth form black
wind Mountain mist which involves the
user rotating their body in order to
create a powerful slashing tornado then
we have the breath of mist style another
derivative of the breath of wind style
this style is used by mu Ichiro taquito
the mist pillar of the demon slayer core
the known form of this style include
first form hanging sky distant mist
which is a thrusting attack second form
eight layered mist which involves a
barrage of multiple slashes one on top
of the other third form d misting blasts
a circular slash with the power to blow
away enemy projectiles fourth form
advection slash which includes a rapid
slash right as the sword is pulled from
its scabbard this is actually very
similar to many of the Coty's that we
practice in Iaido and in the idea we
refer to the scabbard of the sword as a
saya then we have the 5th form sea of
clouds and haze which involves the user
running at the enemy at high speed and
following through with a barrage of
slashes sixth form moonlit mist which
involves the user leaping into the air
and raining down a large number of
slashes on his enemies and finally
seventh form haze which is a technique
that allows the user to come
fuses enemies by shifting the tempo of
his movements in a way that tricks the
opponent's eyes now let's talk about the
breadth of stone style which is one of
the five main breath styles believed to
be derived from the breath of the Sun
style directly it is used by stone
pillar llame himejima who uses chained
axes and a spiked flail as weapons
instead of a sword the known breath of
stone forms include second form upper
smash which involves the user's throwing
an axe and spiked flail at his target in
order to create a pincer attack the user
can then smash down on the chain and
force it to rebound on his target we
also have third form stone skin a
defensive technique involving a barrage
of slashes that deflects the enemy
attacks and fourth form volcanic rock
rapid conquest a two-pronged attack from
a distance that involves spinning an axe
and spiked flail on a chain in order to
strike his opponents from afar next up
is the breath of the serpent style a
derivative of the breath of water style
used by the snake pillar open-eye guro
known forms of this style include second
form venom fangs of the narrow head
which involves the user getting behind
the enemy using incredible speed and
decapitating them and fifth form
slithering serpent which involves the
user swinging a bending sword left and
right an extremely high speed and this
attack can be very effective against
multiple enemies at once then we have
the breath of the Moon a breathing style
that is believed to be derived from the
breath of the Sun directly and a style
whose only known user is actually a
demon this demon's name is kakushi bull
and he is actually a member of the 12
demon moons this style allows the user
to use Crescent moon-shaped blades that
are constantly changing in length and
size which makes it incredibly difficult
to predict the range of this users
attacks known forms include first form
dark moon evening palace a quick single
slashing movement that creates several
crescent-shaped blades second form pearl
flowers moon gazing which appears to be
a series of upward slashes third form
loathsome moon chains which involves two
rapid wings that create a storm of small
crescent-shaped blades fifth form moon
spirit calamitous Eddy which involves
multiple curved slashes that create a
flurry of blades resembling a vortex and
sixth form perpetual night lovely
oonh incessant which creates a storm of
slashes that branch out in all
directions finally we have the breath of
the sun' style itself very little
information has been reliably revealed
about this style other than what I
mentioned already which is that it is
believed that the breath of the Sun is
the original breath
the godly breath that was the first ever
created and the one from which all the
other ones are derived Shin judo ren
goku considers all the other styles to
be inferior copies of the breath of the
sun and he believes that tan Jiro is
actually a user of the breath of the Sun
style we will have to wait for more
information about this legendary style
to emerge but feel free to let me know
what you guys think if you could choose
which of these breath styles would you
like to have the most and if you would
rather create your own unique style that
is derived from one of the above styles
feel free to describe it down below in
the comments also do you think that the
answer the fire-god is one and the same
as the breath of the Sun is it a
derivative of the breath of the Sun or
something else entirely let me know down
below if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more demon slayer content
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification valve a big shout out to
excel Eon for helping me with this video
with the research and with the visual
editing I really appreciate it be sure
to check out xle on on youtube and
social media and set him some love links
in the description you can also follow
me on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest anime news and
updates I want to give a huge thank you
to all of our anime upper patrons for
supporting our work and making our work
possible a special thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress and on hell
crews another massive thank you to our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including baby ray
ace
Ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun
and keelon and finally at the very
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness a
tier reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison and Lord
naksan or disciples of
Lord to ego himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you when you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see our
space cowboys
[Music]